I promise you [__] an album you've
been patiently waiting out a day is
finally present I took my time with this
[__] I put my mind into every line cuz
when inside I ain't trying to regret it
[__] get overhyped and all that hits
ghosts bootleg cab car man university
town music with the homie Hobson who
just got done tearing it down on stage
the [__] tours stop one stop one and
there's seven more stops
I wish the tour was longer man I feel
like it should be in [__] 45 before
that would be cool that would be cool
maybe sometime in the future we'll do
the [__] two tour did it this
connection with you and yellow fan
distorted I know you guys share that
famous stars and straps yeah family you
know what I'm saying is that is that
kind of a brush all together on this one
um kind of I mean Yelawolf we had just
met like about a year and a half ago or
some and we we just had a few
conversations on the phone just just
acknowledging each other to shame
yourself and all that and we both he
found out that I skate and just right
yes and you guys really [__] skate
yeah yeah so yeah so we just wanted just
some homies to just like he was like yep
I'm in town he doesn't go skate or
something so and if we got a collab with
some just hit me it will hit one another
no for someone like that but yes we've
already been always been cool but I
guess he had the [__] Tour idea and
then he threw my name out there to his
people and then it makes sense man you
guys I think you guys share a lot of
fans but then you guys also have yeah
yeah yeah the cool thing is when we both
got that aggression aggressive like
RAF's that so awkwardly enough you are
on tour with with we yell wolf and then
your boy Jarren Benton is on tour it's
yeah it's like yeah yeah the same camp
and [__] um man yo this album like
everyone's been waiting for [__] this
new album forever yeah not a man is
knock madness is finally coming you just
leaked the joint with tech 9 which is
crazy I saw you there
[__] crazy oh thanks man this yeah
glad you like it man
mietek we just shot the video to it the
same day that we released the song so
the video should be out in a few weeks
oh nice okay yeah I got two videos
coming out one called I need help on the
back of your shirt I know you kind of
made a conscious decision to kind of
keep that kind of shoot in mind when you
make music yeah I mean is it hard to
stick to that sometimes it is sometimes
not because like I want I don't want to
see kids grow up in and get influenced
by things in a negative way yeah you
know sometimes it's a rapper I like to
say jokey punch it's just like bashing
meditating with a baseball bat
what is just alignment is just yeah yes
so so there are some things like you can
you can feel when the real songs are
being made so I feel like as long as you
have a healthy balance like yeah yeah
that yeah I'd say that's a good
listening to [__] when I was a kid I
somehow I got brother literacies into
the sickness album I don't know how the
[__] that
my parents really didn't let me get it
but that wasn't [__] up [__] on it now
and I
yes I think I did um let's talk about
all this documentary man you guys
this Punk ball you move it is hitting I
feel like bigger and bigger by the day
bro like a dizzy just was out here
on this tour the Golden Age tour Darren
was just out here where it's and crowds
knowing everywhere from everybody in the
cab and then you guys just put out this
documentary that independent living
documentary talk about that man that's
[__] friends are you can put out your
own [__] documentary about your squad
like yes it's crazy like we actually had
it playing in like theaters yeah and
Kathy I wish I was hoping up that was
funny because I was a calendar day
before you guys are the screening on kid
I would have liked to check it out there
yeah when I was but it came out dope it
came out really don't mean oh and a lot
of people are inspired by they say that
and we show the real gun of what it's
like busy right get in little arguments
you see me as being stupid the whole
goddamn show I feel like that was that
chore specifically was kind of like that
was kind of like you guys are on this
level right now and that was kind of
yeah that guy's only the top voice of
practice that's a very important one for
you yeah that was it yeah it was an
antibody brought us together too because
we all know each other but that soul is
it where we just all really came
together and brother so yeah
that's alright it was it was fun too so
back to the documentary it just it just
explains how you know we all came up it
shows but before and after like shows a
long time ago
like five six people right round
he's a [__] horrible web driver he's
wet period no way around it he is wacky
in the dictionary wack it's like Emma
Davies these to me he's the best rapper
of all time